[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 12 mars 1977 à
fort de france en martinique je suis
judicaël g11 doigts et de la peau entre
les doigts mes pieds sont déformés mes
bras sont plus courts que la normale
aimer mon visage présentant des
symptômes du rhume htv face à ma
différence et pour x raisons mes parents
abandonnent à l'orphelinat
orphelin à la pouponnière un 24 décembre
1977 nous permet qu'une prise de garde
mais pris dans ses bras me regarde et je
prononce mon premier mot maman depuis
ses jours à me confie une étoile qui me
protège toute ma vie et prie tous les
jours
naturellement elle devient ma marraine
durant les quatre premières années de ma
vie je suis ballotté entre l'orphelinat
la maison de ma marraine et les hôpitaux
pour rendre fonctionnel mes jambes et
mes bras en 1981 je me souviens je suis
à l'aéroport de paris je me souviens
j'ai à ma main droite un ballon rouge et
à ma main gauche
je tiens la main de l'assistante sociale
qui m'accompagne et soudain et se met à
ma hauteur et m'annonce judicaël je te
présente les nouveaux parents
je deviens philippe ribière ai vécu mon
deuxième abandon désorienté et après un
long voyage au sud de la france dans ma
nouvelle famille composée de quatre
filles deux garçons et mes deux parents
adoptifs et je me rends compte que je
vais passer le reste de ma vie dans
cette famille où les enfants n'ont pas
le droit à la parole j'ai un petit trou
de mémoire 1 comme tout le monde
et du coup à l'école j'apprends lire je
cours je dessine je fais tout comme un
enfant normal
et bizarrement je pense je constate que
je saurai toujours différents jeux des
autres comme par exemple en sixième un
camarade de classe se moque vulgaire
membres de mes mains et je le tape au
visage avec m'amèneront gauche celle
avec la bosse tout droit chez le
proviseur
et même si je trouve injuste son
discours à mon égard je me souviens
d'une petite phrase qui mine de rien
monsieur toute ma vie on ne résout rien
avec la violence alors je suis puni mon
camarade pas du tout et à mon retour il
vient s'excuser et je lui pardon comme
par exemple lors demande de mes stages
de recherche en entreprise
certains chefs d'entreprises préfèrent
payer la demande que plutôt d'avoir un
handicapé dans son entreprise
wow quelle finesse 1 et la 18 ans pour
bien marquer le coup je reçois un acte
stipulant noir sur blanc que je suis une
personne handicapée de troisième
catégorie
ouah merci hein
j'avais pas vu un essai de leur
expérience
excusez moi et du coup ça m'a posé
beaucoup de problèmes de problèmes
existentiels
je sais plus qui je suis où je vais quel
est le but d'un monde
dans ma vie et d'après mes souvenirs je
me souviens pas qu'on m'ait appelé une
seule fois l'handicapé c'est quand même
réducteur non donc je suis et équeuter
handicapés à vie
c'est du rhin mais ces expériences vous
ramener tout droit la connexion tout
droit avec le chemin de ma vie d'homme
et je sais j'ai compris que plus
personne ne sommes encore à deux mois
plus personne ne me dira comment agir
aux pensées j'ai le droit au respect et
à la dignité
j'ai tout simplement mis en pratique les
droits universels de l'homme qui dit
tous les êtres naissent libres et égaux
en droits en 1994 je découvre l'escaladé
alors autant que je peux rien changé à
mon corps je n'ai pas de force dans les
avant bras l'escaladent n'est pas du
tout une question de physique de force
d'ailleurs ma force représente 20% de la
vote raient l'escaladent pour moi est
une connexion avec nous mêmes l'escaladé
est une connexion avec la nature le
respect de la nature
l'asca la dette une connexion avec le le
vent le soleil le vide se sentir dans
ses mouvements et toutes ces ascensions
m'ont permis de m'affranchir la scala
fut pour moi une connexion dans le monde
des valides pour ne plus cacher sous de
longues manches
mon handicap
en 2002 j'apprends que l' escalade veut
devenir un sport olympique qui dit
olympique dit paralympiques merci et du
coup je suis je deviens le pionner
naturel de la catégorie handi auprès des
fédérations nationales et
internationales je me déplace sur des
des compétitions avec les valides
je fais des démonstrations jeux comme
aux championnats du monde où je
rencontre la plus grande entreprise de
matériel d'escaladé kim démarche et me
recrute je rentre chez moi
gonflé à bloc et je me dis philippe sur
le billard sponsors des habitants
courage et tuer le temps alors en 2003
j'écris je crée un événement en 10
grammes pour faire grimper les personnes
handicapées et des personnes valides
sera même événement des personnes
valides je la remets tes jeux comme
toujours d'ailleurs un handicap
artificiel aux yeux bandés
mais attachés pieds attachés ou qu'ils
se rangent peut-être content de ce ce
que pourrait être un handicap après un
accident de voiture un accident de vélo
maxi donc un cancer il mal à dire sert à
échanger avec ces personnes handi j'ai
trouvé une autre connexion
j'avais des jambes j'ai mes deux bras
j'ai mes oreilles j'ai mes yeux j'ai ma
langue et j'ai mon cerveau et je me dis
que quand même il ya bien d'autres
personnes qui sont beaucoup plus
handicapé que moi alors je renvoie un
peu mes problèmes existentiels dans le
bon contexte et je ne me plains pas en
2009 je décide de faire un voyage à
travers l'europe pour trouver une autre
connexion
je voulais savoir si la france était ou
pas en retard en matière du sujet du
handicap
alors du coup je grimpais surtout les
rochers européen
je fais des compères des conférences
dans les stades escalade dans des
instituts pour handicap et même dans les
ambassades françaises lors de ce tour
d'europe je me rends compte d'un fait
qui me fait changé ma vision de mon
handicap et de le rendre beau pourquoi
devrais-je être parfait pourquoi
devrions-nous être parfait dans la
nature rien n'est pas parfait dans la
culture dans la musique dans la la
sculpture et cetera
on y dépensant des sommes astronomiques
une personne handicapée n'est pas
parfaite
alors pourquoi on a un problème avec les
personnes handicapées
pourquoi avons nous un problème avec les
déficiences physiques mentales et au
moral
la nature nous a donné encore vivants et
nous discriminons j'ai petit les
handicapés les gros noirs les arabes les
juifs un rouquin nez avec un est comme
ça mais un an
déformer et ces sommes ou des modèles
d'infection ou des humains puisque ce
soir nous parlons de connexion
l'escaladé m'a appris à me connecter
avec le monde des valides
encore une fois les scala de fullum et
le seul endroit pour pouvoir communiquer
avec vous rentrez en connexion avec vous
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait tous les tous
les matériels électroniques et sont
censés nous permettra communiqué et plus
on en produit et vous on se parle et du
coup on se parle plus on aime pas et
quand on n'aime pas on exclut on tue
alors j'en ai fait la stricte expérience
trois fois trois tentatives de meurtres
à mon égard une fois en 2005 en grèce où
on a coupé des freins d'un moteur d'un
coup on appelle cela le petit scooter la
deuxième chose c'était il ya pas ses
mots comme ça c'était en 2013
on m'a mis un couteau sous la gorge sous
le prétexte que je suis une personne
handicapée et troisième chose on a mis
une drogue suspecte et je suis mort
trois secondes dans ma vie et je pense
que la connexion que nous avons oublié
c'est la connexion avec nous-mêmes pour
pouvoir accéder aux zones là je me
présente je suis philippe ribière
je suis champion d' escalade depuis 25
ans je suis libre de mes mouvements
depuis 42 ans
mon corps mon corps et mon meilleur
costume une chance unique une force un
art et
un outil de travail et pour pouvoir
devenir philippe ribière stable et fiers
devant vous je les réalise et en
connexion avec vous par les petites
choses de la vie
une attention un regard une blague un
baiser et mon cadeau ce soir sera de
vous dire merci
[Applaudissements]